- Tryin' to get that daddy beard.
You know what I'm sayin'?
- I don't.
(laughing)
- A daddy beard.
(upbeat jazz music)
Today, we are trying Lush beauty products.
- I'm actually really irresponsible
and don't have much of any beauty routine.
- In the morning, I like to wash my face
with a face wash, and then,
I will use a SPF 15 lotion.
- I actually use one Lush product.
It's called Kalamazoo.
It's a facial scrub situation.
- [Man In Red] Oh, dope.
- But it's good for your beard.
You know what I'm sayin'?
So, if you want your beard lookin',
you know what I'm sayin', on fleek.
You should get that.
(upbeat music)
- Pan Galactic Gargle
Blaster Mouthwash Tabs.
- This don't smell like it's
supposed to be in your mouth.
- Nibble the tab.
- [Man In Hat] It's 'til your told?
- And swish.
- Why am I--
- I'm gonna pop it in.
- That says nibble.
- Oh God.
- You didn't nibble.
(spitting liquid)
(gargling)
- I still got, oh?
- Boy, was that yellow.
- Mine didn't taste that bad.
Initially, it was like a little chalky.
So, I wasn't ready for that, that texture.
- I would take this and
pop it before a date.
Think about it.
(upbeat music)
- Do you see at the bottom,
this was made by Chelsea.
- Whoa!
It tells you who did it?
- Rub your lips soft.
Never heard that sentence
before in my life.
- Boy, these lips gonna
be nice and exfoliated
after this over.
- I feel like if I have a
sip of lemonade right now
it's gonna burn.
- They feel like I just put lip gloss on.
- It feels softer and sweeter.
- My lips feel fucking fantastic.
(upbeat music)
- Mine smells just like
cold-brewed coffee.
- I'm supposed to massage
my face for 15 minutes.
Who has time?
- Ooh, it feel so good.
- Very gooey.
- So, we went to the bathroom
and washed off the bits
from our face.
It feels smooth, actually.
- I got to try both,
and I definitely really
like the green one.
It like woke my face up because
it was like minty-fresh.
- I will say I didn't like it.
I felt, my face feels very dry right now.
'Cause you know our skin's just different.
'Cause I feel like it
takes almost too much oil
out of my particular skin.
- It does, and I'm--
- But a--
- More than happy to put it back in.
- Yeah, I really like these Lush products.
I think my favorite was
the lip candy sugar stuff.
- You're doin' a lot of stuff.
You gotta chew up your own mouthwash.
You gotta scrub your lips.
- I really love that
the products are fresh,
like that is the one thing I can say,
like everything tasted, smelled fresh.
So, Lush.
Get you some.
(upbeat music)